Dwayne the rock Johnson got married that's you yeah yeah Dwayne the rock Johnson married his longtime girlfriend Lauren hey Shion yes afterwards Hoshi and said it's so excited to be married to Hobbs or possibly Shah no one really knows it doesn't matter she doesn't care got the rock yeah the big news in the Democratic race for president Ben & Jerry's has released a new ice cream flavor inspired by Bernie Sanders yes inspired by Bernie Sanders yeah it's called cookies and cream corn and it's too spicy it's too spicy I don't like the bits of corn in there I don't know why my Bernie Sanders is an orangutan oh well no wait stupid it's like he's being attacked by bean I know it is that's my Bernie Sanders what else going on in Florida the streets are being flooded with ecstasy pills that are shaped like Donald Trump yeah sources say it's the first time Donald Trump has ever caused a woman to feel ecstasy I don't get that joke